we were discussing ronnie's social media
and we mentioned that he's
been promoting products on his twitter
and instagram and he was like i didn't
promote any product
11.7 alcohol
pretty heavy stuff man when i'm done
with this i won't be able to talk to
anymore so
i'm gonna tell you it's good because i
took the first sip by the time i'm done
i'll probably be laying on my ass
but ronnie says he doesn't do commercial
endorsements he doesn't remember doing
that what's going on
the guy sent me a bunch of [ __ ] and then
i went on instagram and
a commercial i was doing a thank you
right that's called a commercial no it's
a thank you
you got a free product and you did a
plug for it
no i commercial thank you i was telling
everybody how good it was that's all
but you don't know you did a commercial
no i didn't do a commercial
what is a commercial i know it's an
advertisement for a product
i know what a commercial is i'm not
indeed so they tell you how
good it is robin okay
i like the beer i i went on instagram
and i did a
a thing for it oh commercial you want to
call you want to call it a commercial
fine
you call it a commercial to me ronnie
calls it a
okay it was a thing i i didn't do a
commercial i just got on there and told
everyone how good the beer was that's
all
yeah oh exactly yeah got it that's not a
commercial
no it's a thank you it's a thank you if
somebody sends me something
that i didn't ask for that's right
should i just reject it
send it back no you can do whatever you
want you can drink it
but what they're doing is they're
looking at you and calling you a dummy
by doing that because they're gonna go
hey look watch this idiot we'll send
them some beer and instead of paying
them he'll just get on there and plug it
if you wanted to thank them you write
them a note
i did you did it at all i did write them
a note you're going overboard they
didn't really care if you wrote them a
note you're what they call in the
advertising business a cheap date
i guess i'm too nice a guy two nights a
guy yeah i don't know
i don't know i don't ask for money i
didn't never ask for money from anything
for anybody nor should you
oh yes you did you don't drive howard
for free
no i'm i'm talking about a product what
are you breaking my balls for
listen it's 113 degrees in vegas that's
right his brain is frying
no no it'll be fine if you want to
endorse something on your instagram
you better start endorsing air
conditioners because you're going to
need it and generators
you know what that air conditioning air
conditioning
shades how do you like them patio shades
we just yeah yeah
yeah he's got a 50 40 spf
i don't know i went to the front door i
don't know how they got my address but i
got a new air conditioner
hey look at that this is pretty good
fine with me
there's another beer review what's it
taste like though some kind of
like cocoa flavor like a coconut
yeah with coke like cocoa coconut okay
something like that like a like a day on
the beach
oh for sure i mean too lazy you're out
dead you're dead
perfect
great commercial huh just a little thank
you